[Music]
good morning and welcome to trevor
phillips on sunday
the 21st of june marks the longest day
of the year but as it stands
there's precious little daylight on
whether that date will also be the day
lockdown finally comes to an end the
prime minister says he's going to spend
the next week
fi studying the final data before making
a decision
between now and then he's also got to
host a g7 summit
see off possibly the biggest rebellion
from his own mp since the last election
and deal with the fallout from the
resignation of his education advisor
it's fair to say the prime minister will
need every hour of daylight he can get
and maybe some good advice and we'll
have lots for him from our guests
this morning on today's show we'll be
discussing all those topics
in just a few moments we'll be hearing
from the health secretary matt hancock
about that big decision around the 21st
of june
after the government's advisor on
school's catch-up resigned
we'll be talking to the shadow education
secretary kate
green one of the conservatives planning
to rebel tomorrow against plans to cut
foreign aid tom tuggenheit
will also be on the show as will the wh
so's
special envoy on covet 19 dr david
nabarro and we'll be discussing the
safety of on
of going ahead with the road map as
planned with the president of the
academy of medical sciences
dame ann johnson
but first we can go to central london
where we're joined by the health
secretary
matt hancock good morning
mr hancock earlier this week the prime
minister told us
that we have to proceed cautiously on
lifting lockdown
but nonetheless nothing in the data that
he'd seen suggested
we need to interfere with the roadmap
is there anything secretary of state
this morning that you know about
that you've seen that would require
delay
pause or modification
well it's too early to make a a final
decision on that um
as you said the the prime minister and i
and the team will be looking at
all of the data over this week we've
said that we'll give people
enough time ahead of the 21st of june
date when this is penciled in
the next step to be not before the 21st
of june
and the critical thing is to
see whether the four tests that we set
have been met and that's in terms of the
number of cases and cases are
rising slightly the number of
hospitalizations
which are much more flat and that's
because
the third test the rollout of the
vaccine which is going incredibly well
and then of course we've got to look at
the impact of of new variants and we
have seen
a very significant impact of a new
variant at the so-called delta
variant over the last month or so yes
and that that's that's the the big
unknown here isn't it
what you call the delta in uh varian
which a lot of people
still call the indian variant uh
we don't know yet what that's going to
do what's the latest
number on that and do you have any
information on transmissibility we heard
this week from sage that it could be
40 percent more transmissible than
the previously dominant variant so what
is the indian
variant doing to your calculations
well that figure around 40 percent more
transmissible
um it is indeed that's the latest advice
i have
that means that it is more difficult
obviously to
uh to manage this virus with the
with the new delta variant but crucially
after two doses of vaccine we are
confident that you get the same
protection as you did with the old
variant
so the good news is that the vaccine
still works
if just as effectively everybody must go
and get their second jab though
because the first isn't quite as
effective on its own you need that
second
jab so ultimately it does make the
calculation more difficult for the 21st
of june but it doesn't change our
strategy
which is we all need to go and get
vaccinated and
that way we will break this link
from the number of cases through to the
number of hospitalizations
it sounds like you buy the uh the
suggestion made by chris hobson the head
of nhs providers yesterday
that the vaccine has actually broken the
link
between the virus and
serious illness and hospitalizations and
death uh
are you confident about that now well
i've said that
that link is severed but not broken it
isn't completely broken but it
we've made a massive massive difference
the majority of people going into
hospital with covid now
are unvaccinated and that
is obviously that's a challenge for them
but it's good news for all of us because
it shows that the vaccine protects you
from going into hospital
now this week we'll be opening up
vaccines
to the under 30s and so we're getting
a step closer to the point when we've
been able to offer the vaccine
to all adults in this country and then
once we've got people
everybody having had their second dose
of course then you'll get this
protection that we're seeing at the
moment amongst older people
you'll get that protection throughout
the whole adult population
and and that way we can get out of this
and restore our freedoms
but you know the timing of the exactly
when we can take that step
is the big question um we are not saying
no
to the 21st of june at this point we'll
keep watching the data for another week
and critically watching that link from
the number of cases to the number of
people who end up in hospital
and it is absolutely true that the
number of people ending up in hospital
is broadly flat at the moment whereas
the number of cases is is rising
showing that that that uh that link is
not absolute as it once was
secretary of state i want to come to the
point you raised about age in a moment
but
let's just uh close off on june the 21st
if we can if um the data demands
a judgment call because in the end it's
not the scientists who decide this it's
going to be you
and the prime minister are you prepared
for
a modification of some kind not
lifting uh down completely but lifting
most of the
restrictions for example would you
consider
lifting lock down but asking people to
continue to work from home
well we consider all options and the way
that we
have set this out is as follows that
there are there are a series of things
at the moment restrictions on how you
can live your life
that we have said will be part of step
four when we can take step four which
include for instance
um the rule of six and the fact that
there's still some businesses
that are closed but then as well as that
we have
four reviews into international travel
into certification
and into social distancing for instance
um
and we are concluding those reviews um
and doing that work at the same time
and so of course
any of those things could be varied
social distancing for example
well we have we haven't yet set out the
approach to social distancing
after step four and that is something
that we're working on with
our scientific advisors but as you say
guided by the science but ultimately
it'll be the
uh it'll be ministers who make these
decisions one of the things that we
now know is that you know all the
ulsters people like me we've had our
double
jabs uh half the population's head is
fully jabbed
now um does that mean that we're heading
now to a situation where you're going to
want to jab
all children um and
essentially uh make sure that
before everybody gets back to school in
september
all children have been inoculated
well i'm delighted that the regulator
having looked very carefully at the data
and with their typical rigor and
independence
has come forward and said that the
jab is safe and effective for those who
are over the age of 12.
so we're only talking about our children
over the age of 12 here
um and we're taking advice currently
from the joint committee on vaccinations
and immunizations the experts in this
on the uh the right approach
to putting that into practice now of
course
for the time being as of today we're
vaccinating people age 30 and over
next week we'll move to opening up
vaccinations to the
under 30s who are adults so we've got a
few weeks
yet until we come out with a plan for
exactly
how and if we take this forward but we
know that the vaccine
both protects you and helps stop you
transmitting
and i want to protect education as much
as as anybody does you know i'm the
father of
three uh school-aged children and so
making sure that we don't have those
whole bubbles having to go home and the
isolation
especially as we saw over the autumn for
instance you know that
that has big upsides for education are
you detecting anything
in the data that would give give you
cause to be concerned
about spread of virus amongst young
people and children
no and i think that it's very reassuring
that the um
uh that the the regulator has come
forward to
say that the vaccine is uh is safe
that's in respect to the vaccine and
young people in terms of the impact of
the virus on young people
um it is very very rare that people
that young people are affected um
very negatively there is some long
covert amongst
children um and also crucially
they can pass it on and that means that
they have to isolate if they test
positive and then the whole bubble has
to isolate and you get all that
disruption
to uh to education that we don't want to
see so the
so the aim of it of vaccinating children
is essentially
to protect older people not you're not
worried about children
so i'm so sorry i missed that question
the aim
of uh extending the vaccination down the
age range to children
is more because you want to protect
older people than because you're worried
about spread amongst children well
the spread amongst children does have an
impact on others
and critically we know how much it
disrupts education as well
and then there is this uh the problem of
of long covid in some children who get
who
test positive so there's there's plenty
of good reasons to do this
but we also will want to be very uh
careful and make sure that we listen to
the scientific
advice on exactly what approach we take
are you listening to tony blair this
morning he suggested that um
the we should be able to discriminate uh
in favor of those who are fully
vaccinated businesses
should be able to give extra freedoms to
those who can show that they are
fully jabbed is that part of your plan
well this is what the certification
review is going to is looking into
and that will report soon the good news
is we now have the technology available
to do this right if you download the nhs
app right now and uh and you get
yourself registered on it
then you will be able to see your
vaccine status you know if i open my nhs
app
it shows and can prove that i've had in
my case one jab
and which jab and the date that you had
it and so
we've got the technology in place we
know this is going to be needed because
for international travel some other
countries have said that they're going
to require this sort of proof
um and um and so we're putting uh that
in place but in terms of using this
domestically
um we haven't gone there yet we have
this certification
review and we'll be publishing the
results of that question
i do like the word yet there secretary
of state
it sounds that you are actually open to
the blair advice
well the um this debate has been going
on for
uh for months and we've been doing the
work inside government
and uh we'll be coming out with our
answers uh to that soon
when i say yeah the thing is that we
know that this is going to be needed
internationally because some other
countries have said that it will
including
uh for instance uh the eu
and so being able you know my my one of
my jobs is to make sure you
uh and everybody watching has the
ability to prove that you've
had the jabs so that if say the eu bring
this in as they've said they will then
you'll be able to
um to travel when it's safe to do so not
yet sadly but when it's safe to do so
so we we know this is going to be needed
internationally
on the domestic front you know um that's
that's a matter for for michael cove
okay
central state um what you've told me is
the data we're not sure
and so on and so forth um one of the
reasons
that we are uncertain is this indian
variant and i wonder if
you would accept that frankly you've
only got yourself to blame
for this you put pakistan on the red
list at the beginning
of april when the metrics uh
were at a certain point it then took you
a further
um more than two weeks to put india
on the red list even though its
metrics were worse than pakistan uh this
is
your fault isn't it
well the the facts in your question were
wrong i've been through this
uh many times including on this program
with uh
a couple of weeks ago so the positivity
of those coming in from from india was a
third what it was those coming from
pakistan and
at the dates that you mentioned we
didn't even
know about the
seven point b1617.2 uh variant and so
uh that you have to make these decisions
on the data that you've got you can't
make decisions on the basis of data that
you only find out
afterwards uh because it obviously isn't
available so
uh i'm afraid there are some people who
were putting it about that india was in
uh
so there are some people who are putting
it about that india was in a worse state
than pakistan at that moment when we
took that decision
but unfortunately that is not the
question i ask i
i'm reading your data here within days
of pakistan reaching 4.6 percent
uh of positivity you had
pakistan on the red list it took you
two weeks from knowing that india uh
had a positivity rate of 5.1 percent to
put
india on the red list why why
no i i don't recognize those figures
they're your numbers well what i can
tell you what what i can tell you
is that as we saw the case rates rise in
india
and as we saw the uh this new variant
the now
delta variant arriving then we took the
action to put india on the red list and
you know i'm it's tough action but i'm
very glad that we took it in the same
way that this last week
we saw uh the the this
potentially dangerous new variant in
portugal
nobody's going to contest that you made
the right call tough action all
the rest of it it's just it took you a
long a long time
and longer than it could have done and
nobody's going to complain now but i'm
just saying
looking back now would you accept that
you could
have done this days before
the time when you did and remember
during that period it's estimated that
something like 20
000 people arrived from india when
actually
we could have had that them on the red
list
well i'm i'm grinding trevor because um
i i
i i absolutely think hindsight is it is
very helpful
and um of course during a panel why not
say you get more information
but you have to take decisions with the
information that you have at the time
and
you know you can't ask anybody uh to uh
take decisions with information that
doesn't
isn't yet in your hands uh even if uh
even if you'd like to be able to predict
the future
i i'm just reading the information you
had at the time but let's just deal with
something that's happening this week
you want to support the developing world
and you want to use
um their stocks to vaccinate british
children um
are you worried that we're going to in a
way look
like we don't care about the rest of the
world because we're you we're
going to extend vaccination program down
the age range
when actually for example in africa
uh only 2.5 percent have been vaccinated
and we could be
giving more stocks to african countries
now
i i am i'm uh i i'm going to answer this
question but first i'm going to
i'm afraid you can't get away with
making a comment on my previous answer
and then just moving on when the comment
was wrong
you have to take information with the
decisions with the information you have
at the time
and the information that you've been
talking about was not
uh was not available to ministers at the
at that time so
you know that's why we took those
decisions we took the right decisions
based on the information that we
had and of course information came
forward subsequently
moving on to the other question which
was very which is also very important
my first duty is to protect the uk
population
and that does include trying to minimize
uh transmission
and the way that we're helping the rest
of the world
is primarily with giving away
at no cost the oxford astrazeneca
vaccine this was an agreement we came to
over a year ago
and it means that of the two billion
doses delivered around the world
500 million of them are
the oxford astrazeneca vaccine seventy
percent of that
the oxford astrozenica vaccine doses are
in low and middle income countries i'm
incredibly proud of this
and the reason that we've been able to
do that is because we've made it
available
at cost no charge for the intellectual
property from the start
so i'm delighted now there is a global
debate including around the g7 table
about how we can do more to vaccinate
the world but this country
has done more than any other by making
sure that from the start that oxford
vaccine
has been available at cost and that's
why within the kovacs program which is
the program
that is designed to get vaccines to p to
countries that can't afford them
themselves
96 of the doses are our oxford
astrazeneca vaccine
delivered at cost so you know absolutely
let's get this done but
we've been on this for over a year yeah
is this
is this going to be associated with your
big challenge this week
which is over the foreign aid budget
are you going to count the value of
those
doses that you send to africa as part of
the foreign aid
budget in order to drive up the
percentage
um no so the doses that are being
made made around the world 20 different
factories around the world
at no cost that doesn't count as aid
you know it doesn't take aid to help the
world what we've done is we've invented
a vaccine that's easy to transport easy
to administer
and we have we made an agreement with
oxford university and astrozenica over a
year
ago to deliver it at cost so obviously
the money we also put into kovacs counts
as aid
but the really big contribution is is
getting this vaccine out to everyone
as cheaply as we as we possibly can so
it shows that you can help the world
with
far more things than just overseas
development aid and this is probably the
biggest gift this country could give to
the rest of the world
is to make a vaccine to put in the money
into the science
and then to make it available at cost
i'm going to talk to tom tougenhart in
in a few minutes
secretary of state um he is one of
it is estimated 30 or 40 rebels on this
foreign aid
uh amen legislation um
what can you offer him to persuade him
uh
to fall in line
well i i think that the decisions that
the government's taking around this are
entirely reasonable we face a once in
300 year economic interruption
the cost of that to the exchequer has
been hundreds of billions of pounds
so it is reasonable absolutely
reasonable in the circumstances
when we're delivering over 10 billion
pounds of aid as a country
and we're making available this vaccine
at
cost and we have a
have such a strong history in this area
it is absolutely reasonable to take the
decision that the government has
secretary i can't let you go without
giving you the opportunity to reply
to um what has been said
about you by a former senior
advisor at number 10 dominic tummings
told mps last week that you should have
been fired
at least 15 times for lying you have
said since then
that you've always told the truth
there's no middle way here
no room for misunderstanding which one
of you is lying
well i i told the house of commons this
i spoke to responded uh in the house of
commons
uh the week before last about these
comments
um and i was absolutely categorical
about it
um obviously i work incredibly closely
with the
prime minister and i talk to him about
about all things to do with health and
in particularly
covid all the time i'm completely
straight about
what we know what we don't know the
challenges we've got and what we're
trying to achieve
um and that's what i said to the house
of commons
and uh and frankly i think we should
leave it there
cummings made it up to be clear to be
clear
well all i can i i i can't give you an
insight
into that well all i can tell you is
what i know to be true
and that is that i've worked you know
every waking hour on this over the past
year and a half
and um i've been absolutely
straightforward in
answering questions including when we
don't know things as we've in our
discussion today
and whether in public or private one of
the challenges of a
of a pandemic is you have to make
decisions based on
uncertainty you have to be able to
communicate that
understood thank you very much for your
time this morning secretary of state
thanks for having me on this week
the man asked by boris johnson to drive
the government's education recovery plan
resigned
after plans were unveiled to spend just
one and a half billion pounds on the
program
sir kevin collins accused the government
of
a half-hearted approach which risks
failing hundreds of thousands of pupils
now labor is planning to force a vote in
parliament over the issue
we're joined by the shadow education
secretary kate
green kate green
um if i can just ask you
on covid um what do you make of what
matt hancock has just been saying
do you think do you think we're heading
towards uh ending lockdown
on june 21st and are you happy about
that
well it's a very difficult a very finely
balanced decision
for the government and it's absolutely
right that it's taken on the basis of
all the
available data and that it's
transparently taken
and that it's robust uh obviously we're
all keen to see
things get as near to normal as possible
as quickly as possible but that must be
done with public health in mind
and so i would say if we have to
maintain some protective measures
beyond the 21st of june that is what the
government should do but um
i think it is really important there's a
decision taken on the basis of the data
but knowing what you do now what you
know now
um would you basically go along with the
noise that's coming from uh government
at the moment which is
there is no reason yet to
deviate from the road map which
essentially
heads to lifting all the restrictions uh
on june the 21st what i'm hearing
different experts say
is that it's very finely balanced that
it's not a clear-cut decision at this
stage
so i don't think i'm in a position to
say today and i don't think the
government should be in a position to
say today
what will be the answer on june the 21st
i think it's a very finely balanced
decision
um it's one that's got to be taken with
the benefit of all the data on one that
the government has to be absolutely open
and transparent about and accountable
for
are you going to welcome uh the prime
minister's call
to jab the world by the end of next
year i'm afraid i didn't hear that
trevor sorry
i asked you if labor is going to welcome
the prime
minister's call to the g7 to have
the whole world jabbed uh by the end of
ninth of night of next year 2022.
yes i think that's a really good call
because we've all known that unless
everybody in the world is safe nobody is
fully safe and of course
well i really welcome the progress that
we've made in this country with rolling
out the vaccination program the nhs our
scientists have done a wonderful
job and we obviously still have and
people who need to
receive the vaccine here and it's very
important that for example in the areas
where we're seeing
a rise in the delta infection uh that we
have surge vaccination programs put in
place and effective
but i do think that it is absolutely our
obligation
um as global as members of the global
community to make sure that we
are getting vaccines to people in the
countries that desperately need them
and making sure that those people are
safe because that's the right thing to
do morally
and it's in the interest of everybody in
the world and including in this country
on education um you've criticized the
government over its plans
for a catch-up program and sir kevin
collins
uh who you've supported this week said
that the government
would need to spend something like 15
billion pounds
um would you support kevin collins's
program for an extended school day which
is what
most of the money would have been spent
on
well we've put forward our own proposals
which also include
um activities after the end of the
formal school day and breakfast clubs
before the start of the formal school
day
and i very much welcome the suggestions
that kevin collins is making many of
them
are very similar to the proposals that
we are putting forward
we know that activities you know art
sports drama and so on
um schools have wonderful facilities to
offer it's a shame for those facilities
to shut up shop at 3 30
when children could continue to benefit
from them we know that
um children's emotional and social
well-being is as important
to parents and teachers right now as as
making up lost learning
so those activities will give them a
real chance to to enjoy their childhoods
to
to rebuild that social well-being but
also of course
it will benefit children and young
people's learning and so yes
um i think kevin cohen's proposals are
very good
and i do very much welcome the proposal
to use extra time at the beginning of
the end of the school day to offer
those additional activities your
proposals uh
are priced at about 14.7 billion
pounds from the document you've issued
collins uh says 15 billion over the next
three years
okay they overlap but um is the shadow
chancellor
rachel reeves okay with you wanting to
spend
something north of 20 billion pounds of
public money
over the next three years is that labor
policy so
these proposals signed off by rachel and
the shadow treasury team with the
support of the entire shadow cabinet
because we are entirely committed
to giving priority to children and young
people's education
you may have heard keir starmer saying
it was his number one priority
in his interview with piers morgan
earlier this week
we've costed these proposals very
carefully if people want to look at our
children's recovery
plan they can see the detail of every
element of that plan
and how we've costed it we also know
that the government itself and quite
rightly
has set aside a covered reserve to get
the country back on its feet
after the pandemic what we're not we're
talking about is um
how do we spend money that the
government knows it will have to spend
we're talking about priorities here
so i would say that um it's absolutely
right that we should give
top priority to children and young
people that's our responsibility to them
as
adults but it's also in our interest as
a country because
the cost of not spending 14 and a half
billion pounds now
in terms of lost earnings lost
productivity in the future will run into
hundreds of billions of pounds and i'm
delighted and very grateful to rachel
and my shadow treasury colleagues
for their very very constructive support
and help just to be a package together
clear
just to be absolutely clear this does
include an extended
school day um and by the way are
the teaching unions okay with that more
hours
for teachers yes so
what we're talking about is a range of
activities at the end at the end of the
school day some including
sport art drama culture so on there
could be also the opportunity for some
formal teaching and learning
um we're not saying that any teacher
would have to do that and indeed a lot
of the
sports and music and so on might be done
by youth and community groups although
teachers who want to would be able to
and would be paid to do so
we have been in very close discussions
with the the teaching unions and they
they understand that position we've
agreed that we will
make sure with them that we're tracking
um exactly how any extension of school
of activities after the school day
impacts on workloads so that there can
be very quick um
measures taken if it if it creates
unacceptable burdens on teachers
but you know teachers in the teaching
unions are as committed as anyone
to children and young people's futures
more so it's their day job it's what
they care about
and when i hear the government
rubbishing teachers rubbishing the
teaching unions
rubbishing the professionals who've
worked so hard over the last year
to support our children and young people
when i know that we have had the most
constructive and helpful discussions
with them
frankly i think this is disgraceful all
right i think
let's just talk about keep talking about
the money for for the moment
um i see this morning that labor is
saying that
the um tax deal
navigated by rishi sunak should
provide dividends for health and
education um now you've already given
boris johnson
a pretty big tick on his um jabbing the
world
proposition are you going to
congratulate rishi sunak this morning
on um his triumph because usually it's
it's labor who's calling for crackdown
on tech multinationals and
transnationals and
uh the the richest in the world and
they've seen he seems to have done it
labour very much supported joe biden's
call for a global tax floor of 21
so it's it's a first step but i must say
it's disappointing
uh that we have achieved only 15 coming
out of the g7 this weekend and i know
that that is because rishi sunak and the
conservative government in this country
were not enthusiastic were not prepared
to back
joe biden's call for a rate of 21 they
did it so i
i think it's good i think it's good that
the g7 collectively have agreed
to 15 i think it's a start i think it's
disappointing that we didn't have a more
ambitious
21 percent agreed that many of the g7
countries but sadly not richie soon i
wanted to
but at least we made a start and that
will bring hundreds of billions of
pounds into our exchequer
okay green thank you very much indeed
thank you very much for talking tomorrow
boris johnson
could suffer his first parliamentary
defeat since winning that big majority
in the 2019 election a number of
conservative mps
including the prime minister's
predecessor theresa may are planning to
rebel over plans to cut the foreign aid
budget
this all comes just days before boris
johnson hosts
world leaders at the g7 summit in
cornwall
one of the rebels is tom tuggenheim the
chair of the foreign affairs
committee and he joins us now
uh tom tugan had um you want to force
the government to keep
the figure for foreign aid spending at
0.7 percent of gross domestic
products around about 14 and a half
billion pounds last year
and now you need at least 40 tori's to
join you
um as lyndon johnson once said first
rule of politics learn to count
have you got the numbers well we're
cautiously optimistic
uh but the reality is that what we're
trying to do here
is we're trying to make sure that
britain's foreign footprint
that global britain really means
something and and i think that's
absolutely vital to making sure we
achieve
our ambitions and our potential the
reality is britain has a huge
opportunity to shape the world at a
moment of extraordinary flux
and this along with our defense and
diplomatic and trade capabilities
is part of that so i'm absolutely
committed to making sure
britain really is great on the
international stage and the prime
minister has been
as clear as you can possibly be about
global britain being
an ambition for all of us so i'm
delighted that he has expressed support
and and i hope very much that he'll see
that this is an opportunity to
demonstrate it
but but the words his words don't seem
to match the spending
as far as you're concerned one um wheeze
which appears to be
uh doing the rounds is the idea that the
doses that britain might send to
africa and other uh other developing
countries in other regions uh could be
counted
against the 0.7 target
and that actually uh you could make up
the gap
that way now um matt hancock was a bit
uh not too positive about that but would
that be something that you could
accept well i certainly think that
foreign aid comes in many forms
and as matt correctly pointed out the
extraordinary generosity of the british
people in giving the oxford astrazeneca
vaccines ip for free to the world has
been
an extraordinary gift and one that we
should celebrate so i certainly think
the government has done
many things for which it should be
congratulated and that's one
but i also think we need to look at the
way that some of the aid is being cut
in places like syria where we know that
the war has cost
thousands of lives and left millions
displaced or in lebanon
where they are hosting a displaced
population of possibly as much
as a quarter or even a third of their
own population
are internal refugees or refugees from
syria
we know that british aid has done a huge
amount not just for them but actually
for us we all remember the population
movements of 2015 that destabilize parts
of eastern europe
that's what british aid is helping to
prevent and we should be very proud of
it
but i'm i'm hearing that there might be
the beginnings of a deal here if we
could wrap the
uh the relevant bits into um into
the counting of the money you're open
for the discussion i'm sorry i missed
you there trevor
you're open to further discussion i'm
absolutely open to further discussion i
think this is a sensible negotiation to
have
with uh partners in government who have
made some very difficult decisions in
recent years
and i think that the government has
demonstrated that it's listening i think
one of the things that the government
has done
uh well uh in the uh foreign
commonwealth and
development uh office under dominic
roberts has brought together
various elements of aid and diplomatic
influence to make sure we get a
a better delivery on britain's terms and
i think that's an extremely important
action but what we don't want to do is
to
achieve a better delivery under some
extremely
impressive uh civil servants and uh uh
uh
individuals who've been working for
formally for the diffid office
now for the foreign office and and then
we see their their budgets cut
let me put you some of the questions
that might be asked
about uh your campaign time to take them
out
um the government's telling us this
morning that it cannot afford the five
billion pounds that a year that kevin
collins wanted uh for catch-up in
education funnily enough from
the extra 0.2 percent that you want
enshrined in law comes to pretty much
the same amount so
some of your red wall voters might be
saying
oh here we go that's what tories do they
want to spend
all that money on other people's
children a long way away
but they can't afford to find the money
for our children
sorry trevor that's not quite accurate
the the reality is that the government
has simply asked for greater evidence
that the money
requested will uh address the question
in
in in the education field that is so
required
nobody's saying that the money isn't
there and nobody is saying that
uh children in our communities won't
have the support that they need and
quite the contrary the government has
been very clear
that they will get the support that they
need and the only thing that we're
discussing
with the education question is whether
or not
the uh the solutions designed meet
the aim now whether we hope very much
that as soon as they've proven their
need then
come the spending review in in the
autumn then we'll see the money come
forward
according to what is necessary not just
simply a blank check and the same is
true by the way for aid
what britain has done brilliantly over
the last 10
years is under various conservative
governments it has made sure that aid is
very accurately and very directly spent
delivering
for everybody and multiplying our need
because what we've done is we've
demonstrated
that british aid is always well spilt
spent forgive me so
what happens is we draw other aid with
us because as it were other countries
we've done the due diligence i don't
want to leave the education question
just uh on the on the numbers
because there is also a question about
uh
speed and timeliness isn't there if it
takes the government another six months
to decide
how much it wants to put into a catch-up
program and then there's another six
month
uh where it's implemented that's an
entire year's cohort
of children who will have left school
without having the advantage
of any of those programs shouldn't a
decision
be made now you're asking for speed and
i agree with you and i think that this
is one of those areas where the
education department
needs to present the evidence as fast as
possible so that the treasury can
evaluate it but it's quite right that
the treasury shouldn't be
uh pushing money out of the door unless
it's absolutely certain that the
programmes
work so i respect the uh i respect the
chancellor's view that you've got to
check
that the money is going to be uh
delivering exactly what you need
but i also respect the uh education
department's uh demand that we need to
have increased spending and the prime
minister couldn't have been clearer on
this
he has said that the money will be
available the there's nobody debating
whether or not it should be the only
debate is whether or not
it is well spent forgive me but you in
summary you would like to see
more money and you'd like to see it get
there faster
i would like to see the right amount of
money it's it's very difficult for me to
say more money because
until i know exactly how much money is
going to be spent sorry until i know
exactly where it's going to be targeted
it's very difficult to know where it
should be spent
okay i i see that uh you've got an
education expert who's
clearly going to make a contribution to
this discussion i mean frankly i suspect
she wants some of that
anyway never mind um tom let's let's
move on to
um the issue of how
we never go through this again part of
that is going to be
getting a clear understanding of where
this virus
came from do you set any store by the
suggestion
uh from uk and united states
intelligence sources
that it was in fact a leak in china
from a laboratory in china there is
certainly
strong suggestions of that and there is
a strong possibility and it's at least
an inquiry or route of inquiry that
needs to be investigated
if you read the 2012 papers that list
various forms
of research that were being done in the
wuhan laboratory
then you can see that certainly the gain
of function
areas that they were looking at raise
the possibility that this is something
that
we were looking you know that may have
happened now i don't know
whether it leaked from the wuhan
laboratories and my guess is the chinese
authorities don't know
if it leaks from the laboratories
because their culture of fear and
silence
is one that has left them blind let
alone us blind to the causes
do you think that um i know that you've
got other pressing engagements
uh there but just let me ask you one
last question do you think there's any
chance
that we will ever know the truth about
china you've you've
studied this you've been uh uh in many
countries
uh particularly authoritarian countries
do you think that there's any chance
we'll actually ever find out what the
truth is
well i hope we do and this is exactly
what the world health organization
should be pushing for and looking at
because it's absolutely essential that
we do find out the truth but we all run
laboratories around the world that
research different forms of viruses in
order to find vaccines in order to find
cures
and if there has been a leak we need to
know why that was
is it something that could have happened
anywhere is it something specific to
this laboratory
we don't know but as i say the real
problem here is that the chinese
communist party has developed such a
culture of fear amongst its own people
that people are afraid of telling the
truth and there's a very strong
possibility
that we don't find out the truth because
the chinese government itself doesn't
know the truth
and will never find it out because they
have so terrified their own scientists
and researchers that they're
that they won't be able to tell them
thank you very much for squeezing us in
uh against the claims of frankly rather
more important people than anybody on
this show
my apologies thank you
okay this week world leaders will gather
for the g7 summit
in cornwall and ahead of that meeting
the prime minister's called on the
world's richest nations
to ensure that everybody in the world is
vaccinated by the end of 2022.
sharing vaccines with developing
countries is something that the world
health organization's been calling for
for some time
we're joined now by the organization's
special envoy on covert 19
dr david nabarro dr nabarro
i want to come to the point that tom
toughenhart
raised about china in a moment but um
can we just start with the delta variant
uh yes
and what we call the indian variant how
worried are you
well of course uh by the way hello
trevor and thank you
for the opportunity to hear the
interview just now
i know what you're going to ask me in a
second i just wanted to say yes
uh all variants are that are being
looked at right now
that are identified as variants of
concern
are just that they're variants that
collectively we are concerned about and
they are the variants that have either
greater transmission capacity or
the ability to cause worse disease and
all of them are ones that everybody
needs to focus on
but there will continue to be variants
emerging with this virus at intervals in
the foreseeable future
so we shouldn't be surprised by variants
they are to be
expected that's par for the course so
is it the wha's view really that we are
into a world in which
suppression of infection to zero is
impossible and a pointless aim and that
what we really need to do is to learn
how to live with this thing
well you said it and i would like to
stress to you that
humanity is going to have to learn
how to coexist with this virus
preventing it from
spiking and then surging and causing
hot spots of disease and we're going to
have to be able to do this for the
foreseeable future
eradication is not currently a
reasonable
target for the world one signal
of uh that choice would be
uh an approach to international travel
um from what you've said it sounds like
you think
actually we should return to
international travel
with fewer limitations sooner rather
than later
well like everybody i want life to
start working properly as they say i
want particularly poorer people to be
able to get their incomes back
and i want countries to be able to re
redevelop their economies and so does
the whole of the world health
organization
so our approach when working with
governments
is to encourage them to find ways
quickly to work together on things like
international travel
as well as on things like the sharing of
vaccines
with a global plan we do think that
countries working
separately when trying to do with a
worldwide threat
is not the most efficient way in which
to be doing things right now
understood i've asked you about the
indian variant um yes of course this
week we've seen something new
nepal and we don't have a lot of
information about that yet but uh
it's thought i think to be potentially
even
more transmissible possibly more lethal
than anything we've seen so far any
signs
from the who's data that could tell us
more
it always takes a number of weeks after
there is a
sudden surge and thoughts perhaps that a
new variant has appeared
to confirm whether or not this is in
fact a variant of concern
there's a group that meets and reviews
the data as you would expect
and so they've looked at the delta
variant the one that was first reported
from india
but as you say there are new reports of
an additional variant coming from nepal
and those will be examined in the coming
days and weeks
and then we'll know but each time there
is a sudden surge
it does stimulate in one's mind the
thought that there might be a new
variant appearing that wouldn't be
surprising
and and as i said just now that's the
pattern for the future trevor
this virus isn't going away anytime soon
there will be variants emerging
sometimes we'll worry that they're going
to be able to break past the defense
from the vaccines that have been so
brilliantly administered
but we're gonna have to work together on
it i describe it as being
coveted ready being ready for whatever
this virus might bring
are you welcoming the prime minister's
ambition to vaccinate
the whole world by the end of 2022 and
more importantly
do you think it's realistic well i was
absolutely delighted to read that
you see we've always said it's going to
take some time for the world to be
vaccinated but for the leader
of the uk and also the chair of the g77
to put a date on it is wonderful because
this now means that there's a real
prospect that when g7 leaders meet
next weekend they will actually think of
a plan
for getting towards everybody being
vaccinated by the end of 2022
and that would change things because
we'll start saying to each other
how do we use this wonderful gift of the
vaccines that are available
as well as possible to help the world
get ahead of this pandemic
rather than focusing on the interests of
individual nations
one of the prerequisites for all of that
to happen is trust
between nations and between leaders now
um let's talk about china last
year the last february the who more or
less absolved
china said it was unlikely that the leak
had
the uh virus had come out of a chinese
laboratory or indeed out of wuhan
um does wha owe the world an apology on
that
oh gosh i i mean i think all of us who
work in
the issue of this pandemic uh need to be
constantly apologizing because the fact
that this pandemic is causing so much
suffering
is something that is a it's a great
distress and the damage being caused the
world is huge and
people like myself who've worked on
pandemic preparedness for
something like two or three decades uh
really
have a huge responsibility why couldn't
we get the world to be better prepared
now when it comes to working with
nations on dealing with a pandemic
as as as you probably know and i'd just
like to stress it for everybody else
the world health organization isn't some
kind of
independent superpower that can just
choose to do what it likes where it
likes
it has to work within the rules set by
the governments that own it
we are owned by all the nations of the
world and but it has to work with
science though doesn't it
of course so we are on the one hand
trying to do
everything possible to be as straight
and science-based as as we can but at
the same time
we have to decide where we work and how
we work
always trying to make sure that the
countries that we work with
approve of what we're doing we don't
have can't blanch trevor and and i want
to stress that
we do what we're able to do isn't that
the outcome
the outcome of that though dr nabara and
i yeah this is not a personal point
at all in the outcome of that that the
nations that are ready to put
pressure on the whole political pressure
and
china is first and foremost amongst them
get their way and also they get an easy
ride
when it comes to investigation for
example
well i hope not i mean i don't actually
think that anybody is saying that
any one nation gets let off when it
comes to trying to understand
what's happening about this pandemic for
example
when we're dealing with fact with
pandemics it's a
joint effort between national
governments and the who
we are mutually dependent on each other
and no nation
is let off the hook i and and trevor
inside the wh you've got
scientists who just want to do the best
science in the world
and all they do all the time is to push
at countries when countries are somewhat
uh
pushing back at us and we just say give
us what we need
and we're not going to stop that trevor
not going to stop
i appreciate your time and your
directness dr barra thank you very much
indeed
thanks for having me and best wishes to
everybody thank you
now we've spoken a lot today about the
indian variant
and what that will mean for the planned
easing of restrictions on the 21st of
june
the government said that it is looking
at the science about the variant to
determine its impact
so what do we know so far let's ask our
next guest
she's the president of the academy of
medical sciences
dame and johnson dame and
um matt hancock uh told us
this morning that he didn't quite know
where we were didn't quite know about
the impact of the
india variant what what are you making
of it
well i agree with him that we need more
data and this next week's going to be
absolutely critical
in obtaining that data one of the things
that we always have is after the
uh opening up of a lockdown there's
always a delay
between lifting restrictions and then
the emergence of
as we might expect more infection as
people mix together more
and then whether or not that feeds
through to severe disease and and death
now what we have in addition to that mix
is of course
the arrival of this delta variant which
we do understand is more transmissible
and we have seen in the last week or two
a significant uptick in the number of
cases from what was a very low base
what we need to understand is whether
what the risks are of that
setting off a another wave of infection
and also how how well we can do in
controlling it so the data that comes
through
in the next week are very important and
just to remind you that with the road
map
one of the key ideas that we should
always have a significant period
of five weeks between each of the stages
was to do exactly that
because of this difficult issue of the
delay between
opening up and then understanding the
impact on transmission
but clearly this new more transmissible
variant
does uh create new challenges for us
we have got some data and we know that
there is an uptick in
infections but we also know that
hospitalizations are pretty much flat
should we be more worried
about the rise in infections or more
reassured
by the uh lack of an increase in
in hospitalizations well i think what is
reassuring
about the cases that we're seeing if you
look at the age distribution of them
overall we're seeing a much lower
proportion
in the highly vaccinated population that
is the over 70s
but we're seeing more infection in the
younger population particularly
in in young people but also in those who
are
not vaccinated now i've just said that
it takes some time to feed through from
infections
into hospitalizations and deaths now it
is reassuring
that we haven't seen yet an uptick in
the
in the uh in the um number of admissions
and deaths
but we are so three weeks now from
the last opening up and when you think
about it it takes
a week for virus transmission to
increase because the incubation
period and then it's often another week
or two before people come into hospital
after the infection so
we need to watch very carefully what the
outcomes are
but we do know of course that the
highest levels of protection
are now the the 50 of people who now
have both doses
are going to be in the more vulnerable
groups so hopefully we'll see
a a continued unlinking but we do need
to think
about the fifty percent who aren't fully
vaccinated
amen but is is there um is there
a risk that the government could find
itself
in a hole here where it appears to have
moved the goalposts
uh six months or a year ago we were all
worried about hospitalizations
and deaths it feels now as though the
conversation is much
more about just in fact not just but
about
infections um is there a danger that
what people will feel is we
sacrificed we stayed at home we complied
because
we didn't want to overwhelm the nhs we
now know that's not going to happen but
now you've given us a new target
which is don't get infected and we have
to
comply and stay at home for that is
there a
a concern here that we might appear to
be moving the goal posts
i totally understand your concern you
know in the end we're going to have to
if you heard earlier from david navarro
live with this virus and try and
minimize the amount of severe disease
that it causes
but we still got i think quite a lot
more to gain
from this virus from sorry from the
vaccination program
there's you know we've still got quite a
significant number of
more many more people millions more
people who can fully benefit from
this vaccine and i think that is that is
the very
difficult decision we certainly don't
want to go on delaying
uh you know delaying forever it's going
to be a very finely judged decision
when we see um see these results so one
of the issues of course as you know we
are getting millions probably about
um three million people getting their
second dose
each week and another uh three million
or so getting second dose or a first
dose each week
but as we know there's a delay between
getting the those and being fully
protected
so i think that's the very fine balance
the modelers in may
showed you could set off uh you know
quite a third wave and that was quite
very that is very dependent both on how
transmissible the variant is
and the fraction of people who are fully
vaccinated so
sorry so a third wave in your mind is
still
plausible well i think the the size of i
mean
depends how you define a wave you know
um and i think the model i mean this is
again
we we have a lot of uncertainties but
the modelers looked at this back in may
and there were concerns about this i
haven't seen the latest modeling because
now we've got much more data about the
vaccine uptake
and the effectiveness and so on um so i
think you have to consider
that the vaccine the vaccine does two
things it reduces the risk of disease
and it reduces the risk of transmission
so you want to make sure that you're
getting
you know using it as much as you can and
we've got
i think we've got a lot more benefit
still to get from it as we continue
uh to roll it out um and the question
the big question really is
the extent to which we see the extent of
transmission
with this this new variant and also
whether it does translate into
further admissions now i think we're
going to have to look at that very
carefully in the coming week
because of exactly the delays i've
talked and talked about and looked at
the data including the modeling
the newer modeling daymond thank you
very much
indeed thank you and that is it for
today's
main show we've covered a lot of topics
from variants and vaccines to education
and aid after this short break we'll be
going
uh through everything we've learned from
our guests in trevor phillips
the take sky's deputy political editor
tom coach is back on the beat and he'll
be joining me
for that so don't go anywhere we'll be
back
[Music]
you